so you decided to do a documentary
entitled dark girls
yeah i decided to put a documentary
division to my company and i put my own
money up
with my then partner chanberry and just
something you should never do in
hollywood but we believed in it
and we had a documentary about racism in
the black community called dark girls
with dark with dark skinned women what
they've gone through including my sister
and
family and i wanted to talk about
because there's so much pain because
young girls today
in playgrounds are still going through
that
we made it and uh toured it around the
country and
by the grace of god uh oprah winfrey's
folks saw it
and now i have a three picture deal with
oprah what for you the light girls what
is a man
and what is a woman and now the dark
girls book
will be coming out harper collins picked
the book up november 4th
the dark girls book is coming and now
harper college is talking about
possibly doing the what is a man
book and what is the woman book also and
i'm also creating a cell phone app
company
i'm creating brands now so that if i do
a project
it's not only going to be a film with a
feature film or
a television movie or a documentary it's
going to be a brand so i'll have the
film
a book and a cell phone app
you